Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Well, amen. And good morning. My name is Mark Kellerman.
I'm the residency director here.
And uh, gosh, I'd rather not stop.
I'd like to continue
to bask in the holiness and the glory of God.
So why don't we just do that for a moment.
Let me pray for us one more time.
Almighty God, again, we thank you for the truths
that we have just sung.
We thank you Lord for the glory
that you are and that you have.
Thank you Lord, that you would condescend to come
to a place like this filled with a room, filled
with people like us,
and that you would move in our hearts, that you would speak
to us, that you would address us,
that you would have your way with us,
that you would be revealed to us was.
And God, we just respond in worship.
We say that we love you, we honor you.
And Lord, we want it to be with more than just our mouths.
We pray that our lives would continually be changed
to reflect you in worship, that our lives would be lived
for your glory and honor.
And Lord, we thank you for your mercy in our lives.
Thank you for the words
that we'll consider here in your holy and written word.
And I pray you would speak it
to us now in Jesus mighty name.
Amen. Well, if you have a Bible,
please join me in the book of Psalms.
We're continuing our series in the book of Psalms
and we're at Psalm chapter 74.
And as you turn there, lemme just ask a couple of questions
to kind of get us started.
First off, I would just say, have you ever faced trials
or struggles that just wouldn't go away
in your journey with God?
Are there questions that linger and even at times haunt you?
You know, we love to hear the stories
of God at work in the world around us.
We call them testimonies.
We love to hear the ways in which God is saved
and redeemed and rescued.
But what we find difficult is life
between the problem and the remedy.
And we need to have eyes of faith even in those moments
when the answer has not yet arrived to our prayers
and to our pleading.
Perhaps you're troubled by the world around you,
the culture at large
that is on full blast in rebellion against God.
And we wonder, does God see that? What is his reply?
And it burdens us, I think at times.
So if that's you, if, if you can relate to any of that,
then I think Psalm 74 will be a helpful guide.
In fact, I would encourage you to view Psalm 74 as a bit
of a tour guide along that journey as we seek
to trust God in uncertain and dangerous
and at times difficult and dark times.
So in this chapter in Psalm 74, we encounter
a man, the author, the Psalmist Asaf,
and he's grieved and he's overwhelmed by his circumstances.
He's unsure about the future.
He can see clearly the problems of the past and the present.
And he's asking God to intervene.
And it begins with this sort of potent cry.
We read in the first line, Psalm 74, verse one.
He says, oh God, why?
Why do you cast us off forever?
Why does your anger smoke against the
sheep of your pasture?
Now this psalm is similar to Psalm 73,
which we saw last week.
And then also as we continue into the future,
Psalm 79 when we arrived there,
actually these are very similar cries and prayers
and Psalms, indeed, we, as we've seen the book
of Psalms are, is the book of p songs.
These are the prayers and the p songs of God's people.
But a, as we get there, uh, the,
the thing I wanna consider in this chapter is that,
you know, we're not able, we just don't have time
to wr out all of the various issues that arise,
all the different things we wanna see
and ask about this text.
But the goal is to take it in as a whole.
And, and my hope is that you'll come away with some handles
and footholds on Psalm 74 when we're all done.
So you might even think about it this way, great,
if you're like me at all and like a visual learner
and you think graphically, then think about it like this.
So Psalm 74 is essentially exists in
three main parts.
So there's the beginning, the middle
and the end, the first, second and third parts.
Now the first part
and the third part, like if you're reading downward,
they are linked.
If you're familiar with the way the internet works,
you might call them hyperlinked.
And this is a reflection of, you know,
what Pastor John talked about several weeks ago.
There is a Hebrew, uh, style of writing referred to
as a chiasm.
And this is a sort of layering of issues and points.
So the top relates to the bottom
and then differing, uh,
layers within the text relate to each other.
They're kind of linked in that way.
You might think of concentric circles
or the outlines of a target
and with a bullseye right in the center.
But the way that I want you to think about it,
and I think this is helpful to me
to think about Psalm 74 this way, is
to picture it in your mind like scaling a mountain.
And I've got this image here that I drew up.
Hopefully it's helpful. What we see is that the psalm,
first he beg the psalmist, he begins in the valley
of his circumstances and problems
and he's crying out to God in his grief, in his pain
and in his despair.
And then what he does is he shifts his focus away from his
circumstances and his problems and he thinks about God
and all of his glory and power
and promises and his faithfulness.
He meditates on God and he worships God.
And then that becomes the catalyst for his ability
to then descend back along the path,
following his his journey
and to descend back into those realities with confidence
and faith and the ability to pray to God with boldness
and to know that he would be heard.
And so with that in mind, we get started in the first
section, which also provides our introduction.
Lemme just read the first three verses.
Oh God, why do you cast us off forever?
Why does your anger smoke against the sheep of your pasture?
Remember your congregation, which you have purchased of old,
which you have redeemed to be the tribe of your heritage.
Remember Mount Zion where you have dwelt direct your steps
to the perpetual ruins, the enemy has destroyed everything
in the sanctuary.
Do you hear the anguish in this man's words disaster
had struck and Asaf he wrote with a sense of this terrible
question, not only had God disciplined them in his judgment,
but the fear that seems to be
tangible in his words is this question,
has God cast us off permanently?
Has God perhaps abandoned us forever?
Would this always be the case? Would he always be angry?
Would his posture towards us be one of opposition forever?
And I think the question here for him was,
would his circumstance ever change?
Because the only way they would was
by the grace and the power of God.
So he begins here with this question, why?
And you know, I do take this why to be a bit more
of a rhetorical question.
I don't, I don't think that he's actually asking God to sort
of enumerate the reasons.
Like I don't think he would be satisfied by the Lord saying,
well, okay, asap, let me tell you, there was, you know,
let's see, 1, 2, 3, 4, 15 million.
How many, how many things do you want?
I don't think he's looking for an explanation.
I think this is the hard cry of pain
and of anguish of his own uncertainty.
I think the reasons are clear.
If you read the Bible and you know, uh, the back side
of this story, which I'll mention a little more about in a
moment, I think that the reality is
that he is just expressing his sense of pain in the moment
because of course God has not changed.
It's just that the, uh, that circumstances
they appear this way.
It's like, I love what one author said.
He said, this is the desperate, this is a desperate psalm,
but it is not the song of an atheist.
This is the psalm or the whale of the cry of a true
but struggling believer.
I mean, this guy wouldn't even be praying if he really
believed God was not listening.
He wouldn't even be praying if he thought
that it was, it was pointless.
There was no one there or
that God was always had already determined against him.
He's crying out to God
because he actually believes that he hears him.
He actually believes that he is for him
and that is why he is praying.
And so in verses two and three, he calls on God
to remember his people and his place
and to do something about it.
He says, direct your steps to the perpetual ruins.
Run to our rescue.
It's like pick up your feet and come our way.
And this is how the psalm gets started in
this is our first point.
If you're following the outline, we see the psalmist,
he grieves in loss and pain.
And I think it's part of the lesson we take away is
that it's right to grieve in our loss and pain.
Sometimes we think it's a, it's a matter of faith.
If we it's or it's a matter of unbelief.
If we acknowledge our problems
or we say, man, I have this issue
or concern it, it's
actually the only place you can begin if you're in the
valley, the only way up is to recognize
where you are on the map.
So we grieve in our loss, in our pain.
Let me continue as we read in verses three to nine,
direct your steps to the perpetual ruins.
The enemy has destroyed everything in the sanctuary.
Your foes have roared in the midst of your meeting place,
they set up their own signs for signs.
They've come in and they've redecorated their symbols,
their banners, their flags, they put them everywhere
and they've torn down the Lord's.
They were like those who swing axes in a forest of trees
in all its carved wood.
They broke down with hatchets and hammers.
They set your sanctuary on fire.
The profane, they profane the dwelling place of your name,
bringing it down to the ground.
They're like lumberjacks just cutting down everything.
They're like vandals going in and just destroying.
As they went, they said to themselves,
we will utterly subdue them.
They burned all the meeting places of God in the land.
We do not see our signs.
There is no longer any prophet
and there is none among us who knows how long.
The context to what's going on in this psalm,
the background if you will, is that God had rescued
and redeemed the people of Israel out
of all the nations of the earth.
And he had called them to himself.
And he did that for a very specific reason.
First and foremost, this was the family to whom he was going
to bring the savior of the world into the world.
He was going to come from this race of people,
but among them as a nation.
The goal and the desire of God for them was that
as he said in so many different ways, you are a,
you are a holy, you are a chosen people,
you are a royal priesthood.
A holy nation called out of darkness into light the idea.
So even in the people of Israel, they had priests
that represented God to them as a people.
But this comment here that they were called
to be a holy priesthood as a nation, reflects the fact
that they were called to represent God
to the nations of the world.
They were called to represent the
nations of the world to God.
And so their role in part were priests of God most high
to represent him.
And that was a very much a part of their calling,
God's reason for drawing them out of the nations.
But the Jewish people had rebelled against God.
They had reengaged in gross immorality and idolatry
and sin for generations after generation after generation.
And God had warned them and he had wooed them
and he had threatened them and yet they had scorned him.
They had scoffed at him and they had ridiculed him.
And at this point, God's patience had worn out.
And when it came, his judgment reigned down hard
on the people of Israel.
The result was that the wicked
pagan Babylonians had triumphed over God's people,
slaughtering and enslaving them.
All that they had known and loved have been lost.
And at this point in Psalm 74, it appears
that likely even years had passed
and they were wondering what the future held.
God seemed silent and there appeared to be no end in sight
and no remedy possible.
Jerusalem had been invaded, the temple destroyed
and the people conquered.
This was their circums, excuse me,
this was their circumstance.
This was the valley of their realities
and of their situation.
This section concludes in verses 10 through 11.
Again, we hear this refrain, how long,
oh God the foe.
How long is the foe to scoff is the enemy
to revile your name forever?
Why do you hold back your hand, your right hand?
That is like biblically the sword, hand the sword,
the the hand of power
and of action, take it out of the fold of your garment
and destroy them.
Excuse me, God's patience.
Um, sorry. And so here, this is an impassioned prayer
for God to hurry up and to defend his people.
I think ASAP represents the remnant of God's people.
He's not one that has been a rebellion against God
or he has come to repentance for that.
But he is among those who still believe in God
and are left with the consequences of
what other people has done.
And yet he is dealing with it nonetheless.
And there's two main things that are at stake
that we hear over and again as he asks this, how long
and why and cause God to act as we see
that his circumstances are in his mind,
he's asking God to intervene.
And then also we repeatedly see
that he is concerned about the honor
of God among the nations.
That God's name is being defamed because of these things.
And that is one of his concerns.
So this is what the psalmist grieves,
this is his location on the map.
And this brings us to our second point, which is,
if you're following the outline, it is that we believe
in eternal realities.
So just listen here as we enter into this next section, how
dramatically the tune changes
as we rise up from the valley of discouragement
and soar into the heights of who God is and what he is like
and what he has done.
We read about it beginning in verse 12, yet
God, my king is from
of old working salvation in the midst of the earth.
He begins by saying He yet or
but is another thing he might say.
He says all that's true.
But this also is true.
He says to himself, there is something else
that I need to consider.
And here he shifts from his circumstances
and he calls to mind these things that are true about God.
God's glory and power, his acts
of power in the past, his promises about the present
and the future is Colossians three,
two said He's actively setting his mind on things
that are above.
And we continue and read after verse 12.
Yet God, my king is from of old working salvation.
In the midst of the earth,
you divided the sea by your might.
You broke the heads of the sea, monsters on the waters,
you crush the heads of leviathan, you gave him his food
for the creatures of the wilderness.
You split open springs in Brooks,
you dried up ever flowing streams.
Yours is the day yours also,
the night you have established the heavenly
lights and the sun.
You have fixed all the boundaries of the earth.
You have made the summer and the winter.
In the first section, the first 11 verses
the psalmist calls God to remember, he calls on God
and says, oh God, remember your people, remember your place.
Remember your promises. And here he shifts gears
and he calls on himself.
He calls on his people to remember God.
He says, oh God, remember us.
And then now he shifts gears
and he says, oh us remember God.
And this is an essential aspect for us for prayer.
Anytime we are wrestling with something that is unknown
or uncertain or difficult or hard
or bringing us down, we call on God.
God remember me, but we must call on ourselves
to also remember God.
God, my king is from of old. Verse 12.
He is sovereign, reigning, timeless,
working salvation in the midst of the earth he is saving,
acting, intervening.
As this section continues, he's seen as creator,
sustainer, and savior.
And the psalmist is calling all of these things to mind.
The examples that he lists here, I think seem to come to me.
They come from examples, from the exodus of his establishing
of his people delivering them out of bondage
to slavery in Egypt and also God's act
and power in creation.
He parted the sea, I think possibly the Red Sea
during the Exodus.
It was his power over the great monsters on land and sea.
This can be taken different ways,
but I think it's symbolic for the powers of Egypt,
both on land and in the sea.
When he parted the waters and they were rescued
and then rained down the ocean upon their enemies,
he split open springs and Brooks,
after they passed through the wilderness
before entering in the promised land,
they crossed the Jordan on dry land
because it also parted before them.
Likewise. So he dried up streams, he
provided water in the wilderness.
He owns the day as well as the night.
He made all the planets.
He made the moon and all the moons, the stars,
the asteroids and meteors.
He made black holes every dimension, whether it's seen
or unseen, he made nebula, corks and quasars and asteroids.
He set the boundaries to space and time
and the laws of physics he dreamed up
and put into place geology and weather
and nature, God's power and ownership in
and over all things.
And this is the God he calls to mind.
He says, God, call, remember me, remember us.
But he says to himself, oh God, oh, oh me, oh us.
Remember, this is our God.
I love this quote by g Campbell Morgan from
a generation ago.
He says, talk, he's commenting on Psalm 74.
He says, things could hardly be worse to the eyes
of sight, human sight, the first part.
And then came the declaration of what the eyes of faith
beheld the second part, in spite
of all the seeming apparent contradictions, God was seen
as king working in salvation.
And then he says, further, the man of faith is never blind
to the desolation, the problems.
We don't pretend we don't see them. No, we see them clearly.
We see all the terrible facts. But he sees more than that.
He sees God. Therefore his last word is never desolation.
His last word is always salvation.
And we see this happening in Psalm 74.
I love what this other author I read said, he said,
what the psalmist believes here begins to engage
what he grieves.
And that makes all the difference as he begins
to encourage himself with these eternal realities.
God is great and God is good.
And we need that kind of clarity when we face the struggles
and the trials and the mockery
and the uncertainty that we encounter in the world.
So this is where we see asap, beginning
to scale the heights of God's glory and power and promises.
Um, I've got a picture of a mountain view
of this is overlooking.
So, so you know, if you've ever climbed a mountain,
then you know it can be hard to get there,
especially if it's tall, high, big one.
And yeah, and sometimes even along the way you might feel
like, I'm not sure that
I'm actually gonna make it to the top.
But here's what happens when you come out there,
when you scale the heights in this regard,
when you think about the glory of God
and you force yourself
to take your eyes off your circumstances
and to fix them squarely on God is you reach a place
where you can actually see more than you thought was there.
You, there's so much you take in from
that kind of a vantage point.
You can see where you've been.
In fact, you see things you walked right by
and didn't even know they were there.
And then you can see all the journey along the way
and you can also see where you're going
and you see what's ahead.
And even though it's hard and by the end
of the journey typically you're far more tired than when you
started, it's downhill from there.
It's all downhill. And you have perspective,
a vantage, you have vision.
And it enables you to descend back into the realities
of your struggles and your problems
and your life with faith and confidence.
Knowing where you are, knowing where you're going.
And this is the thing that I think fuels our faith.
And we see this in Psalm 74, again, as the,
as the psalmist is setting his mind
on things that are above.
I wanna encourage you when you're in this moment,
to just take the time to enumerate the glory of God.
You can flip through your Bible, ransack your Bible, looking
for the glory of God, the acts of God, the promises of God.
If it helps pick up a theology about God
and read the nature of who he is and what he's like.
Think about all that he's done
and indeed all that he is going to do.
We see this in Psalm 74.
We are not blind to trouble problems or our pain
or circumstances, but sometimes we are blinded by them.
And we need to have the spiritual vision
and sight to see God, to see more than what is going on.
It reminds me of an old song,
I think it's called Lead of Love.
It said, I had to walk through through the rocks
to see the mountain view.
But looking back, what I see is I see the lead of love.
I see God leading me even when it was hard.
So here at this point, the psalmist is better equipped
to reengage his realities
and he comes back down at them in faith.
It's like what one author said,
that worship is the solution to our problems.
Worship is the answer to our questions.
It is the catalyst for confident prayer, and
therefore we want to approach God this way so
that we can be fueled in our faith in that regard.
Our second point is that we believe eternal realities.
So now this brings us to our last section in Psalm 74,
and it's verses 18 to the end.
And let's read it. Uh, if you wanna follow along,
re remember this, oh Lord, how the enemy scoffs
and a foolish people reviles your name.
Do not deliver the soul of your dove, his people
to the wild beast.
Do not forget the life of your poor forever.
Have regard for the covenant, for the dark.
Places of the land are full of the habitations of violence.
Let not the downtrodden turn back in shame.
Let the poor and needy praise your name, arise.
Oh God, defend your cause.
Remember how the foolish scoff at you all the day.
Do not forget the clamor of your foes, the uproar of those
who rise up against you, which goes up continually.
So 10 times in these six verses, the psalmist calls on God
to save God's people and to defend his honor.
And he does so like this.
He says, remember the scoffing and reviling.
Do not abandon us or forget us.
Have regard for your covenant promises.
Let us not turn back in shame. Let the poor and needy us.
Pray your name arise, defend your cause.
Remember, do not forget the scoffing
and reviling, the reason that we can pray prayers like that.
And the reason the psalmist prays like that is
because he knows that God hears him.
He knows that God is aware, he knows that God remembers.
And he knows that God can and will act to rescue
and redeem and to restore him and his people.
And so this is where our third point, uh, this is
where we come in our outline.
The third point is that we plead with God to intervene.
We grieve our circumstances.
We believe in the truth about who God is.
And we plead with God to intervene.
There's a variety, all this variety
of specific requests we could talk about, uh, at, at length.
But this psalm ends here with a bit of tension in the air.
And I kinda wanna highlight that for us.
Um, you know, on the one hand at this point,
the psalmist, okay, so if you just think about
that's the end of the psalm.
And and there's really not a resolution
other than he has started where he was, he ascended
to the glory of God and then he pray confidently in boldly.
And yet in the Psalm itself, there's not
actually a resolution beyond that other than the confidence
that he is heard, that God knows that God can
and will act.
Now we do know, of course, as we look at the history
that we read in the Bible,
and we know the story of what God had did in the world,
we know that this man's prayers were all answered.
I don't know if it all came the way he pictured it
or if it all happened in his lifetime, but God rescued
and redeemed his people.
The temple was rebuilt.
And so much so that enough time elapsed that again,
the people of Israel rebelled against God.
And again, the temple was destroyed.
So in our past
and in his future, God answered this man's prayers.
But there is that uncertainty left in the Psalm itself.
Another thing is that I think that
whenever we read a psalm like this,
it it can be sort of uncomfortable.
Like, I'll be honest, when I first read through this, I,
I felt like, man, this is a little depressing.
It's a little depressing to think so long
and openly about these kinds of problems.
But I think one thing that it does that is important for us
to consider is
that it challenges us at like a heart level, kind
of the idolatries of our lives.
What I mean by that is we see a person
or a a people who have lost, uh, all sense of ease
or comfort or prosperity or convenience or control
or self-determination.
And that threatens us as human beings. Like that's obvi.
All those things are good things,
but that's what idolatry is, is it's anything that we serve,
uh, more than God.
And so whenever we, I, at least for me, I read these things
and I think we face a bit of
that when we read a psalm like this
because it feels threatening.
It's like, man, uh, these things are hard and challenging.
I want God to answer those prayers.
But the question remains if I don't have them,
then is God enough?
I think of the apostle Paul.
I said he, we don't know what it was.
He said he had this thorn in his side
and pleaded with God to take it away.
He said three times. And I think he means by
that three seasons of time, he's begging God.
And what was the Lord's reply?
The Lord said, Paul, my grace is sufficient for you
because my power is perfected in your weakness.
There's something I'm doing you don't understand.
And in the end, Paul was satisfied with that.
And it's something that we need to hold in mind
because the truth is God tests us.
He tries us, he purifies us in some of those hard times.
And the truth is there's always more going on than we see.
And we can believe that as we trust and follow God.
So likewise here, the very end
in Psalm 22, 74, 22,
and 23, he says, arise, oh God, defend your cause.
Remember how the foolish scoffed you all the day.
Do not forget the clamor of your foes.
The uproar of those who rise against you,
which goes up continually.
They mock, they scorn, they revile, they ridicule,
but God brings them to judgment.
This reminds me quickly of Psalm two.
Psalm two goes like this, why do the nation's rage
and the people's plot in vain, the kings
of the earth set themself
and the rulers take counsel together against the Lord
and against his anointed saying,
let us burst their bonds apart
and cast away their accords from us.
But he who sits in the heavens, this is God. He laughs.
The Lord holds them in derision, then he will speak
to them in his wrath
and terrify them in his fury saying, as for me,
I have set my king on Zion, my holy hill.
I will tell of the decree the Lord said to me,
you are my son today.
I have begotten you ask of me
and I will make the nations your heritage
and the ends of the earth your possession.
You shall break them with a rod of iron
and dash them in pieces like a potter's vessel.
Now therefore, oh kings be wise, be warned.
Oh rulers of the earth serve the Lord with fear
and rejoice with trembling.
Kiss the sun lest he be angry
and you perish in the way for his wrath is quickly kindled.
Blessed are all who take refuge in him,
the nations of the earth.
Even sometimes this thing rises up in us.
We mock against God,
we scorm we ridicule him in our culture.
We're doing it right now.
Just turn on the nightly news
and what the promise and the certainty is.
The warning is that it will be no small thing.
And God will write us down in judgment because he is a holy
and a righteous God.
And we will give an answer and account.
The Bible says every slight word will be given an answer to.
But this is true of any warning in the Bible.
If God didn't care
and didn't wanna be heard,
he wouldn't issue any kind of a warning.
Implicit in a warning is an invitation to change,
an invitation to turn, an invitation to
return to God.
An invitation to the biblical word is repent.
That is reorient from a life.
Live for yourself to pursuing your life. Live for God.
It's turning from your sin.
And to him, who is the only one who can forgive
and save and change you.
The Bible says, today is the day of salvation.
The Bible says that today.
If you hear his voice,
do not harden your heart against him, but respond.
And so I would just say, if there's anyone here in this room
you've never trusted in Jesus,
and you realize, you feel like, Hey, I'm that rebel.
That's the story of my life, then don't leave this morning
until you have trusted in Jesus Christ.
Come talk to any one of us.
We'd love to lead you along that journey
because we've been there too.
'cause every single one of us is a rebel,
an enemy against God in our own nature.
Amen. Every single one of us.
And we all deserve the wrath of God.
Yet he has lavished mercy on us.
He has reigned down mercy on us in Jesus Christ.
He has saved us more than we would've ever even asked for.
Amen. This is a bit of the journey
of Psalm 74.
Even as he weeps over the destruction of Jerusalem,
there was another man who wept over Jerusalem.
About 500 years later, the Lord Jesus, at the end
of his earthly life
and ministry, he was about to go to the cross
and he wept over the city
and he said, yet again, people are going to invade
and destroy because you do not realize the time
of the season, the moment.
And it was that their savior, the Messiah, their king
had actually come.
Psalm 74, the temple had been destroyed
because of Israel's sin and rebellion.
And yet, in the life
and ministry of Jesus,
there was another temple that was destroyed.
He said in John two 19, in 21, destroy this temple.
And in three days, I will raise it up again.
But he was speaking, it says, of the temple
that was his body where they failed.
Jesus Christ succeeded where you
and I fail, Jesus Christ succeeded in his life
and death and resurrection.
And every single one of us must trust him
and embrace him and follow him.
Amen. How are we doing on time?
We're going long. Uh, so here's what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna skip this part and land the plane.
You know, there's a lot going on when we bring
these kinds of prayers to God.
I think our reminding him, you know, it seems weird
to remind God of something like as though he could forget.
We know he doesn't. Um,
but there's a way in which we entrusted to him.
I if we had time, I'd read Philippians four.
It says, cast all your anxieties on him.
It's 'cause these things are heavy.
They're harder, they're hard for you to carry.
They're hard for me to carry. We need bigger shoulders.
And we put them on gods.
He invites it and he helps us to care.
Likewise, I think as we do that, uh, he,
we also align ourselves with the way God sees the world.
We, we even align ourselves emotionally with God.
And, and we are shaped by that.
Part of prayer is not only asking God things,
but it is also being conformed to his image.
As we think about the truth of who he is and what he's done.
It honors him when we pray like that.
So, uh, this is, so it brings us to our,
it's our final point, which is where we trust in the future.
We trust in future grace.
This is where we live in the moment.
Uh, we ascend the heights of the glory of God.
We descend back into our realities
and then we proceed in trust in the present and the future.
Grace of God that he provides for us in this way, our pro,
our problems, our issues, our struggles,
they become like a proxy for experiencing God.
There are opportunities for us to encounter him.
Romans 8 28 says, God somehow, amazingly uses all things
for our good and for his glory.
And we see that over and over again.
You might say that the fix is in.
It's like God has his thumb on the scales.
Humanly speaking, we're like, that's cheating.
That's a problem. But here's the truth about your future.
God has his thumb on the scales.
He has already solved every single one of your problems.
It's just a matter of us getting to
that point in history and time.
And that's what we'd call future grace.
That his grace will sustain us now
and it will sustain us when we get there.
And it will sustain us, sustain us beyond his way.
In a moment we're gonna sing a song.
Sing in the line is I know how the story ends
and that's the thing we fix our gaze on.
So when we're faced with protracted trials
and questions that haunt us, if we're, if we're sort
of in the midst of a story that God is writing but writing,
but we're not yet to the victory side of that, we persevere
in the face of taunts and mockery in our culture.
We trust God who sees and hears them and knows them
and even redeems people like that
because we know he redeemed people like us.
We grieve, we believe we plead, we trust in future grace.